okay why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone to our demise
Thursday conference and annex II there's
probably hopefully people out there in
cyber-land listening in because between
we have pretty good social media
coverage between the two of us
keep an eye anyways so today is one of
our special talks so as all the locals
know we have our Thursday conference
some of them have specific designation
or whatever we'll call it today's talk
being an ideal talk the informatics
discovery lab and then we're actually
adding another one next week a week from
today
will actually be our first clinical
informatics Grand Rounds which we need
to do as part of our new ACGME
accredited fellowship and clinical
informatics and but the the talks are
just always on the usual Thursday time
and they have different designations so
some of them are are plain ordinary
research talks but we're always here
usually on Thursdays at 11:30 and for
the last several years we've actually
been streaming them and so people can
listen in over the web which I've done
from time to time when I've been out of
town and wanted to hear a talk and so
we're doing that today and then as a way
of allowing people to ask questions they
can actually tweet with the hashtag D
mice calm DM IC e conf and it doesn't
happen that much every now and then it
does it did when I was watching in
Riyadh Saudi Arabia at 10:30 at night a
couple years ago and I did tweet at
Julie d'Auvergne when she was I think
she was defending her
dissertation proposal so anyways our
speaker today is Keith Moon and dick
Gibson here said it's great that you
bring in these national luminaries and
keep this certainly one and what I said
to him national luminaries he's here
taking a course in our masters degree
program which keith has been in the last
couple years it's actually been quite a
joy to have him in the program I knew
him a little bit before he enrolled and
he certainly brings a wealth of prior
expertise into the program as a
standards developer author lecturer etc
and he's made good progress through the
master's degree program and he happens
to be here with a number of others who
are in the room for a short course that
we have or a hybrid course was the
official name that we call them which I
happen to be teaching on evidence-based
medicine in anyway some we thought that
while he was here we might as well tap
his expertise on fire which if you don't
know you should know because fire is
it's sort of like the perfect storm as
as we've spent our thirty billion
dollars on electronic health records
over the last five years that don't talk
to each other we realized that we need
interoperability in a hurry
for the first time we've been talking
about interoperability for decades but
anyways and the kind of the standard
that has emerged because of limitations
in hl7 version two and three is this one
called fire fast health interoperability
resources and some of you know that I've
been talking around the department for
the last year or two saying you know we
need to pay attention to this it's
important anyways and when taking cut in
two keeps time too much but just by way
of introduction his I don't know if it's
a fish if it's a his official job title
but he is a standards geek
or GE and he's held another what it says
on my card so what it says I'm his Karen
said it must be legit like I said he's
he's a lecturer and author he's he's
been involved with hl7 and other
standards organizations hie over the
years his book the CDA book about
clinical document architecture is well
known
he's been on a number of ONC committees
and maybe his most important thing is
that he's a student in our master's
program although that won't be for too
long because I'll eventually graduate
he's also known as the motorcycle guy I
don't know if he's going to say anything
about this motorcycle but if he is I
will let him say that and then just the
talk today as I said is an ID I'll talk
in informatics discovery lab which is a
initiative in our department headed by
Aaron Cohen to try to integrate more
with the outside world in terms of the
skills and talents that we have in
informatics so I'm gonna sit down at
this point and thank you so I'm gonna
talk to you today about fire and why
it's a hot topic or interoperability and
we'll get a little bit into that I sort
of feel bad coming out here to Portland
talking about fires because you know I'm
driving back and forth to classes every
day and that's all I hear about on the
radio is all of the wildfires we had
here and then last month but fire here
is fast healthcare interoperability
resources as bill mentioned I'm a
standards geek for GE healthcare it does
actually say that on my business card
the secret though is that when I wear
business cards I have to type in all the
stuff that goes on it so that's not my
official HR title but that's the title
it's on my card and that's how I
introduce myself to everybody my role in
gene healthcare is essentially to
represent GE to standards organizations
like
helped health level 7 or hl7 integrating
the healthcare at a prize or ihe and
also to national activities what I'm
going to be talking about today will
cover shortly some introductions talk
about what fire is and maybe even what
it isn't who's doing it how it's being
developed who's involved what kinds of
things you might do with fire we're
gonna have some interactive pieces on
that you're gonna learn a little bit
about fire and then you're gonna tell me
what you think you might be able to do
with this and that's actually going to
also help inform the development of the
specification we will actually take a
look at the fire specifications online
so a couple years back hl7 decided that
they were gonna make the hl7 standards
freely accessible to everybody and when
fire came in fire said we're gonna open
source specifications so you don't even
need to be an hl7 member to get access
to some of these important developments
here look at what problems fire might
help you solve we'll do a little bit of
interactive exploration where you can
sort of talk to me about a problem that
maybe you have where you think fire
might help and we can explore a little
bit together how that might work so to
put this up here hl7 Fire CDA some of
these things that I'm going to be
talking about are registered trademarks
of hl7 that's the usual trademark and
copyright and actually that fire logo is
also a registered trademark um so so
that's me and some of you I've already
met and many of the others of you
haven't so I'm gonna start in the back
of the room with the troublemakers okay
and just find out who we have in the
room so I want two things so so who you
are and what do you want to get out of
this and who
yours can include your name and maybe
who you're affiliated with and then what
you want to get out of it
so we'll start back here
okay interesting implementation
challenges great so the young lady
trying to figure out what kind of pizza
she's going to get there okay
okay
terrific
yes we did
so you might want to hear a little bit
about smart
okay terrific so you have some space
from hom we have some space operational
look at some of those good
excellent
so we pre-populated the room with my
evidence-based medicine class and I'm
going to try to tie some of this to
evidence-based medicine as well
the chief clinical research informatics
officer so another c-level title
somewhere in there or chief level title
mmm like that one later
Lorenzen great question yeah okay
so push your buttons and when you talk
okay great yeah hi I'm Rick my I'm in
the on lines master program from Canada
and I thought when you're talking about
fire yesterday I thought it was both the
forest fires
I'm Steve Chamberlain I'm a new postdoc
fellow here and I'm Dustin piezo I'm
student in the MBI program and I'm
hoping to be both entertained and
educated by your presentation today
awesome
hi I'm Elspeth King hocks I'm also in
the MBI program and a current student in
the evidence-based medicine course
interested in interoperability and what
you'll be saying I'm Aaron Cohen I'm
faculty in the department I've had the
IDL effort as bill said and I'm very
interested in finding out more about
what fire can and can't do which I guess
is the same thing is it gonna live up to
the hype or not but kind of that
direction I Keith I'm Dick Gibson a
physician and voluntary faculty member
here at D mice and interested in how
likely it is that vendors are gonna pick
this up and on what timeframe I have a
slide for you you know hi my name is
Jenna and I'm a student in the MBA
program and I'm interested in just
learning about fire myself
I am Nelson Centris I'm a theatrical
care faculty at the University of
Chicago and my interest is in
integration of various devices like
ventilators monitors and the EHR to
build decision support tools in real
time
alright I'm slide for you as well
Cornell entrance climb MBI student and
positioning format assist in Phoenix I
would like to know how do we reconcile
medication data between EMRs for example
we struggled with transitioning people
from next-gen to Cerner for three months
we eventually made it for allergies
couldn't make it work it may be how can
fire help you solve your problems which
let's come back and look at that one
that's a great problem hi my name is Ben
quarter I'm a second year masters
student and I'm mostly interested in
interoperability you already I'm bill
Hirsch and I saw there was we tweeted
about the free pizza it seems to have
been effective hi Keith I'm Elizabeth
Parker and I'm also in the idea with
Erin and Deb so I have one last
introduction to do and to do that I'm
actually going to turn my back on the
audience so this is actually a painting
done for me by a woman by the name of
Regina Holliday Regina is an artist in
Washington DC whose husband died of
cancer about four years ago she painted
a great big mural on the side of a gas
station telling her story and in so
doing came to national attention and has
now been paid painting the backs of lab
coats and sport coats etc people in the
health care profession to tell their
particular story so you can see the
motorcycle here that's motorcycle guy
there's this guy with this sort of
Vitruvian shape that looks like he was
originally wearing a jacket it's because
I do have it one of her jackets that was
painted with a Phoenix on the back of it
and and the jacket exploded and turned
into the motorcycle vest and what I'm
doing is burning down silos or exploding
silos of information with fire and that
was her interpretation of what I do for
my day job so that's so if you can
actually look her up
it's a holiday with two L's and the
jacket or that this particular the
sleeveless jacket as she calls it the
only one that exists is part of the
walking gallery so I don't need to go
through all of this because we've
already done a lot of that but let's
talk about what is fire here so first
off you're all fairly familiar with the
fact that this is a new standard from
health level seven all right it is also
what we call a restful api for granular
health data so this is not how I'm going
to send you the entire summary of
everything that went on about patience
if I want to get to the meds we get to
the meds so that we can do some
reconciliation or if I want to get labs
or imaging results or claims data or
quality data we can get to some of that
granular data and we can you do that in
a way that we engineers call restfully
which is basically using the web and the
standards available for the web um it's
a standard that's got broad support in
the industry more support than I've ever
seen from anything coming out of any
healthcare standards development
activity oh and I would have to say in
my history I spent some time doing
development with standards bodies such
as the w3c and I worked alongside people
who develop standards such as XML a
director of product that I worked on was
co-chair of XSLT these are general IT
Standards Fire has this much buzz as
they do in our industry and as much
support well it is and I will talk about
how it's an easier way to do things
we'll actually see a couple of examples
you're gonna see some code you're gonna
see some pointy brackets we're gonna
make this very simple and painless
though for you fire is also the source
of many bad puns it's perhaps the
single best marketing thing that ever
happened to hl7 by accident right
because now you have this standard
called fire and everybody can talk about
how it's this hot new thing or it's
setting data on fire or interoperability
on fire and the media just loves it
so it's sort of a meeting angel I gotta
taya in organizations their volunteer
organizations that really don't have a
whole lot of fun funding for marketing
having an accident like that is
wonderful because it means it just sort
of promotes itself um there are a couple
of insider jokes about fire
ein-zwei-drei theater alright theater so
if you pronounce fire theater fhir it's
for hl7 version four okay which means
all of the people in Canada who've been
will know pushing all ahead on version
three I have a great deal of fear okay
so these are some of the just the inside
jokes about fire so it's a new standard
that's developed by hl7 it stands for
fast healthcare information resources
and you're also going to see that logo a
lot showing up it is a new standard but
how new is it really well this has
actually been under active development
in hl7 for something like four years and
it's been rolling around in the back of
people's brains since even before then
the chief architect like what we call
the you know one of the fire chiefs
probably the head fire chief in hl7
Graham grieve is Australian native who
in August of 2011 started working on
this and actually he was working through
the summer before even August it was
transferred to hl7 in 2012 so he he
actually created this
as part of something that was called the
fresh look activity that was going on in
hl7 in the 2011 period that was a board
appointed task force from hl7 originally
headed up by Stan Huff from
Intermountain who many of you may have
heard of they did one of the working
group meetings they had a bunch of
people come together and present a bunch
of different ideas one of them
eventually spun off and became Simmi
which is clinical information modeling
in issue that's looking to come back
into hl7 now and then there was this
other activity which wasn't called fire
at the time which would but which was
what was to become fire it went through
about another year's worth of
development and we published a ballot so
a document that went out that says
here's what we think is what we should
be doing with the specification went out
to all of the hl7 members they said ya
know maybe etc and then we came back and
spent you know another six months
looking at all that feedback literally
seven hundred eight hundred comments on
the specification that came back revised
the specification response to that and
then published in the beginning of
January 2014 yes the draft standard for
trial use so so what is it what does
that mean draft standard for trial use
it means that hl7 thinks this is good
enough for people to start playing with
okay this is not its finished form
I think it's Pokemon if any of your kids
Pokemon it you might know a little bit
about the date they change shape for
over time and then they have a final
form well DST you want is not fires
final form well we are at the stage
right now where the second draft
standard for trial use is in QA it's
been published there QA version
is actually up online you can see what
is very likely to become the second
edition of the DST and it's not unusual
for a big stander to go through a couple
of these cycles of it's not quite ready
yet it's not quite it's better it's a
little bit better and gets improved over
time so that's expected to be published
real soon
now I'm not even going to quote a date
we're in QA we're looking at it we're
fixing the spelling errors we're fixing
the last little problems there's no new
material at this stage that's gonna
change it and this is not the last time
this is gonna happen there are future
versions so some of the work on things
like financial transaction is still in
its very first form and it's got more
evolution that's got to happen
it is a RESTful API we'll look at what
does it mean to be restful on a couple
of slides here but it basically means
it's supporting the web it's using the
same standards that the web uses to
access information you know you're all
familiar with the Lego right the
building blocks the classic sort of
example of how we want you know or
operability at work everybody pulls out
the Lego metaphor okay so I have my
mandatory picture of a Lego block up
here um what we're using this as a
building block for developing computer
software so how many people here play
with Lego as a kid
how many shapes that you have when you
were kid I I remember about five or six
but four okay how many shapes you got
today there's probably a thousand I have
a set at home I could probably count at
at least 50 or 60 and they start to get
a little bit specialized um but the
complexity of that there's still a lot
of similarity crossed a lot of those
shapes and the variation the difference
between that one block long three level
high
narrow thing between it being eight and
being being sixteen things long that's
not that big of a variation but how many
resources sort of gives you an idea
about complexity so DST you won covered
the core resources covered
infrastructure it covered a lot of the
clinical resources and we had fifty
resources in that first edition yes to
you one now DST you released to has
double back about a hundred and four
resources so a little bit more than
double what my confidence in intervals
are there but close to double um and
we're saying about a hundred fifty
resources expected in the final standard
and I actually feel pretty comfortable
that with that one hundred and fifty
sort of upper limit as being pretty
solid for what's going to come out when
we get final oh and what's planned right
now we know we have we're preliminary
calling a 2.1 release of the DST you and
I'm certain they'll be a 3.0 release of
the DST you before we finally get to the
final stages they're about six different
kinds of resource in fire so that's sort
of like a go I got sort of the square
chunky blocks and I have the long narrow
blocks and I have the blocks with the
wheels on them and the blocks with the
holes on them we have clinical resources
for common clinical uses you know what
you would normally think of my problem
medication allergy lab results kinds of
things my patient my provider etc move
into the next step of I need to track
people places and things nouns care
processes
I gotta order a med would like to have
this patient have a referral those sorts
of activities going on there's a lot of
infrastructure you need pieces
you're gonna need media you're gonna
need to have support binary resources to
deal with your dike near huge DICOM
images because we're not going to turn
all that huge chunk of image data into
anything other than the binary blob that
everybody already knows how to work with
then we start to get into some resources
that are going to ensure
interoperability these are resources
that talk about fire itself my server
supports these capabilities when it
responds with a particular resource
these are the vocabularies that we
support so you can start to actually in
real time understand what the systems
are doing um and have some resolution of
well okay how much interoperability can
I get with that server let me go query
its conformance resources and find out
what's going on there and then you have
profiling what guides what
implementation guides and other
activities does this support and then
financial resources so unlike what we
did in the 70s and the 80s where we
focused on coding for financial reasons
and doing all of our electronic stuff
for the financial side that came first
and now we're gonna add codes for the
clinical side what we're doing in fires
we focused on the clinical side first
and the financial stuff that was sorry
you guys sort of got the back feet on
this however it's a lot of interest on
the financial side of sort of
leapfrogging from today's EDI level
standards which are based on UN and in
fact work done in the 50 60 70 s and
sort of leapfrogging into the next
generation and saying yeah we'd like to
do fire to so those are the six
categories we'll look at each of them at
a fairly high level so these are your
clinical resources
we have our gene intolerance clinical
impression so this is what I think's
going on with this patient condition so
essentially the the core of what you're
going to see on your problem list but it
could also be specific findings or
symptoms so at different levels of
medical judgment the idea of condition
and we don't call it problem because
you're gonna have things like pregnancy
well that shouldn't be a problem but it
certainly is a medical condition that
has to be dealt with detected issue sort
of rolls up the idea of contraindication
or other issue that we need to be
concerned with family member history
procedures risk assessment you get into
care planning so what's my plan what am
I trying to do not sure why nutrition
order is in care planning but I think
maybe that has to do with where people
thought I know it recently moved it used
to be over here in this column as a
matter of fact I didn't even change the
column head where it used to be
procedure requests refer or class
divisions prescription and as I said
this is also a moving target this is a
this is a thing we're still working on
in hl7 lots of stuff going on about
medications and then some resources to
deal with immunizations so if you're
trying to do your medication
reconciliation
you know you might want to be looking at
the medication statements in the
medication orders and the medications
that might actually be reported or
identify in the medication order in the
medication statement to say these are
the things that the patient's telling
you that's going on or then I'm actually
seeing listed for this patient and let's
get all of that data and make try to
make sense out of it diagnosis specific
results so an observation could be a lab
result could be a vital sign any sort of
coded or measurable finding
diagnostic report which is not just a
single coded finding but a collection of
them put together as part of a
particular test so you're not going to
have just the observation you're gonna
link that observation with the report
and the interpretation and everything
that goes along with that and associated
with that you could have also a
diagnostic order your imaging study
related with the imaging study I might
have a key image or not just the key
image but a specific area on that image
that I want to highlight so I can
highlight images and then you know all
of these results you're going to need to
be able to talk about things like the
specimen or the body sight people places
and kinds of organizations and ways that
people in places are grouped together
devices
so we had somebody over here who is
interested in devices fire actually has
three specific resources one to talk
about the device itself and you know
where do we actually assign the good ID
right the new FDA assigned universal
device identifier there's a place in
device for doing that but we also know
devices are actually made up of
different pieces
and each one of those might also be a
device um so we have a way to describe
that through device component and then
devices have metrics they have measures
that are being produced configuration
parameters etc that we also need to
manage at a particular level then we're
going to be managing the patient so now
we get into workflow and I have my
encounters my episode
CAIR communications i have back at four
so you go into your portal when I send
my doctor a message I'm gonna get a
response back that says okay you know we
need to have you come in and do XYZ of
course I've only had a portal in my
practice for a couple of weeks yet so I
haven't actually tried that capability
out to see how well that works but it's
there so you have a way to track that
communication as a fire resource dealing
with all if you're scheduling and then
lots of the workflow that goes on and
care I'm gonna request something I'm
gonna get a response back so you're
gonna see that pattern fairly commonly
I'm gonna I'm going to have a request
and a response I'm gonna request
something be supplied to the patient
might be medication might be a
wheelchair crutches and those little
mobility devices that you see on
late-night television the delivery of
that particular device I request for
communication with you please you know
send me that stuff you said you were
gonna send me device use requests and a
device you statement so all of the
different workflows that are associated
with that I'm not sure why this is not
displaying the way it displayed when I
ran through all this last night but I'm
not going to go ahead and play with it
infrastructure supports the
architectural framework so we have ways
to actually build a questionnaire build
an assessment form build a history form
though whatever and get a response back
every resource has the ability to
associate the provenance of that
resource so who created it when was
created where it was created what system
created it what device was it from etc
all of that thing that helps you
understand the reliability the resource
the history of it what happened with it
which is not the same thing as its audit
trail
audits have to do with access requests
and additions and deletions and
creations etc so we have resources to
deal with that documentation different
ways to put together a document it's
called a composition in fire you're
basically creating this thing that is
composed of a bunch of resources and is
human readable document reference and
document manifest document reference as
a way to reference an individual
document that might be stored somewhere
else a manifest is a list of documents
we use that an awful lot when we're
communicating about patience um when
you're doing an imaging study and you're
actually building a key image note what
you're doing in that space is building a
manifest of the list of key images that
the physician should take a look at when
you're talking about the history that's
associated with a patient you're
building the list of documents that a
physician might want to look at so you
have this notion of document manifest
it's going to be very use useful in
health information exchange a basic
structure so binary media bundles are
things collections of resources that
aren't necessarily considered to be a
whole composition they might be in
response to a query so it's part of the
infrastructure of a basic resource which
in in all of the world of standards and
hl7 version 2 you have the OB X segment
and in version 3 you have the
observation rim class these are sort of
the horrors of the standards world you
put whatever in it that fix anything and
so the idea behind basic is what we need
a place to stick that the stuff that
doesn't fit in anywhere else but it's
not really an observation we need a
place to deal with extensibility on
understand that when people do this with
their OB X's or their observations what
they're really doing is extending the
standard so that's what basic is is the
place to support expense ability some
infrastructure that IT geek care about
measure the patters what happened to
this outcome what's the error here what
are the parameters to this particular
request that we made etc how do I turn
this into a subscription that I can just
sort of connect back to regularly sort
of like an RSS feed terminology crucial
if you're trying to understand what's
going on you have to know that we're all
talking the same words one of the great
things about that I've learned about
healthcare is sort of the use of common
terminology internationally right
so when you say proximal and distal as a
physician every other physician in the
world understands what you're talking
about no normal human patient like me
will realize that you're talking about
near and far you know we say front and
back we stay near and far you have a
whole different set of vocabulary very
precise meaning um and you need that to
convey understanding right but I'm sure
you're never talking to your patients
about distal and proximal right because
you've got to be using the right
vocabulary to talk to them as well so
terminology important to be able to
access terminology important to be able
to talk about the structure of things so
that you can do stuff with it important
to understand what a system can do what
it conforms to what the operations it's
able to do look like and the kinds of
searches that you can perform these are
sort of to the computer the help button
on the Google page if you could ever
find it there is actually place where
you get information
that says here's how search works here's
how this operation works and oh by the
way here's everything that I can do
today when you plug a printer into your
computer how do you think the two of
them understand Oh your printer your dot
maker if you have this much resolution
and you have all of this other stuff
well there's a negotiation that's going
on there and it's because the computer
can actually ask the printer through
that USB connection who are you what do
you do what sorts of operations do you
support so now we have this available in
fire something that we have not had in
hl7 version 3 hl7 version 2 or anything
that sort of went before and fire goes
yet one step further in saying and if
you want to write an implementation
guide you can write the implementation
guide in fire you can actually create a
fire resource that explains all of these
things that need to be understood and if
you want to make sure that somebody
actually does what the implementation
guide says it does you can also create
resources to say here's how you could
actually test this at critical from my
perspective because we create imply
create an average of one or two
implementation guides a year and the
various standards organizations but I
work in and we wind up throwing that
over the wall to another group that
builds these test scripts but these test
scripts are combinations of shell
scripts and Python and all of this stuff
that you need this huge infrastructure
to install and play with here now we
could have the test script be described
in a way that a computer can understand
and then it could figure out how to go
off and execute it using Python using
shell commands using whatever it needs
to to accomplish that and then we get to
the financial area which some folks
might be interested in right you know
what's the patient's coverage we need to
check to see if they're eligible for
this particular service like two
enrolled them so that they can get
coverage now that we've verified that
they're eligible for this particular
service we perform the services we'd
like for you to pay us okay here's your
claim back saying yes okay we got your
claim it looks good and you know a month
later
well look we just paid you for that
claim a way to reconcile the payments
and oh by the way another way to
communicate where you can say to the
patient here's how you benefited from
our services I know people in the
insurance world who say an explanation
of benefit is neither okay but we have
an explanation of benefit resource that
so that piece of paper you get back from
your pair that says oh you went to the
doctor they did this in such service
they built so much here's our reduction
here's the amount of your deductible
that has to apply and here's how much we
paid and ultimately that last column is
always zero I don't know how that works
they've got a great job great model and
and and then there's a total at the
bottom that says this is what I'm gonna
have to pay and then that shows back up
as a bill from the provider and three
other providers and three separate bills
so explanation of benefit we have a
resource to handle that
so now you had a brief introduction to
fire where can you find the
specification well you go to WWH l7 org
slash fire and that will bring you to
this page this is the current draft
standard for trial use that is the most
recent quote-unquote official version
there are a number of versions that have
been published and here's the QA preview
so we'll go there this is what's going
to be coming out soon to a theater near
you that all the developers are going to
be actively testing in early October and
then you can look at the resources and
get in drill down into each resource etc
um the other thing that I want to show
you is on each of these pages when you
start at this home page right under
implementation there is a downloads page
you can download all the technical
materials that you need to implement
fire developers love this but even
better yet the entire specification the
fire specification right up top there
you can download this entire collection
of web pages and put it locally on your
laptop or host it on your corporate
server or in your organization's Network
and everybody who needs to can have
local access that you have to worry
about oh I can't get through my firewall
off date I have to add hl7 to the list
of organizations that I've got you know
the white that add them to the white
list so that I can get there when I'm
sitting in the hospital trying to access
the network you say well let's just not
even try to fight that battle let's just
put it out locally on the network and go
all the appropriate other stuff that you
have to do when you install new software
on your network
so that you can have access to it all
open source too so there is an open
source license for all of this material
so let's talk a little bit about support
there were a couple people here who had
questions about who supports this so one
of my colleagues John murky also works
for GE Healthcare he's been on the fire
management group since it was formed in
hl7 so this is the governance
organization in hl7 that is made up of
hl7 members who are very involved in
making sure that fire succeeds we are
also using fire internally as part of
our new development if you've heard
about predicts for healthcare and all of
that other stuff that our marketing
people put out some of that's going in
their common well health alliance which
is a group that is like Cerner McKesson
Athena health all scripts and I don't
even remember all that the list of names
and it's growing well they used version
0.65 so even before DST you want in some
of their early specifications for how
record locators would work how access to
documents would be given and they're
looking to update that to new version on
that's according to a presentation from
David McCauley at the EHR member
Association meeting in hims last year um
epic announced that they would be
supporting it they made that
announcement at their users group in
2014 they're now rolling out versions of
epic in 2015 that do support it I don't
know what that actually means for
organizations that are currently using
epics such as OHSU but it certainly
means that you should be asking
questions about your organization if
you've got
an EHR and you want to find out if
they're supporting the standard you
should ask the question and the answer
might be well yes that's in our new
version which you don't have yet okay I
hear that a lot and you know sort of
like yeah I'm sorry you know you want me
to fix it but then you also want me
anyone coming into solid at your site
immediately after we released the new
standard and there's time oh it takes to
get that out um other supporters
athenahealth Cerner meditech McKesson
they've all demonstrated the ability to
use fire presented materials and hymns
or somewhere else publicly to show that
they're actively supporting it and
they've all been participating so fire
in hl7 does something called a connect
asan sort of patterned after what NIH
econnect Athan so their goal is to
become like an ihe connect upon where
you've got several hundred people in a
room or several hundred more than
several hundred in a room with several
hundred machines in a room trying to
test interoperability between multiple
vendors um but they're more like a
hackathon right now where they're taking
the standard they're trying out new
pieces of it making sure all this stuff
works um so all of those vendors that I
just mentioned had been involved in some
of those activities we've also had folks
from Oracle folks from IBM folks from
Accenture
who've been involved in some of the
activities at connected on checking
stuff out seeing what's going on poking
at things lots of health care provider
organizations are presently supporting
development and standard some of them
financially some of them by form and
consortium and do various interesting
things are being very involved in
leading consortium that are doing some
things so bi DMC how many people know
who the CIO is if bi DMC right John
holem code
part of something called the Argonaut
project very involved in the development
there Boston Children's Hospital has a
an MD / engineer by the name of Josh
Mandel who is one of the fire chiefs one
of the software developers who is
actually pushing the standard ahead
Intermountain Healthcare Stan Huff very
involved in some developing some
consortium healthcare organizations
developing smart based apps to support
this Mayo Clinic Partners HealthCare
System VA all involved so so how many
people here are involved in in a
healthcare organization that is
presently supporting fire how many of
you don't know whether your organization
is supporting fire or not and how many
people do here know that your
organization isn't supporting fire okay
so you know the question you might want
to ask is so how do you change that how
do you get involved and we'll explore a
little bit of that so we talked about
some of the EHR vendors there are also
interface engineers who are supporting
fire these are the ones who have
announced that they're going to be doing
stuff with it or have already done
something with it
I'm not telling you anything that sort
of secret knowledge that I have this is
based on public information so core
point Murph sort of the open source
interface engine a lot of people like to
use because it's open source
Orion the core points like way up there
and you know best in classes they're
there they're marketing skills that they
like to give cue Vera cue Vera's
let's see they're in Salt Lake City but
that folks that I often work with
because we used
in some of our products um initiative
supporting fire so ihe integrating the
healthcare enterprise is a profiling
organization so it's like an sto but
they build implementation guides rather
than standards um we did six seven eight
I've lost track probably up to nine
profiles in the last year based on fire
we talked about Colin well
Argonaut is I don't know at this point
it's probably somewhere between 1/2 and
3/4 of a million dollar project working
alongside hl7 to accelerate the
development of fire well health care
services platform consortium so there
you have Intermountain and the VA and
Cerner and several other organizations
working together to build a platform to
support an app store it is based on two
things smart and fire hl7 fire um Owen
sees standards project the data access
framework is profiling fire for use with
us national projects and one of the high
tech grant projects a smart project in
which Ken mandala Zac cone and Josh
Mandell actually come out of was an ONC
funded grant project all and that's how
Josh originally got involved in doing
the fire development as Doug said you
know talk to the smart people and I said
you know you guys need to be paying
attention over here and doing some stuff
with that so they put Josh on it and
josh has been a tremendous help in the
development of that work well
interestingly enough the u.s. is the
late comer to a lot of the efforts that
have been going on it's this effort
started in Australia we have very strong
leadership the fire chiefs come from the
Netherlands Australia and Canada there
are three and you know are there three
that are sort of the acknowledged fire
chief
Grande grieve blight McKenzie an email
Kramer who Australia Canada and
Netherlands so we're sort of playing a
little bit of catch-up
open-source implementation so when fire
went BST you 1.0 back in January 2014
there were three or originally there
were two and then a week later
there were three full open-source
implementations of the servers on three
different platforms for the
specification I haven't seen that since
XML in terms of standards and I've never
seen that in healthcare we basically had
DST you reference implementation the day
the DST was published that's a level of
quality that is above what we currently
do in healthcare standards more often
than not so the de-facto hl7 reference
server is built by Graham grieve it's on
something called Delphi with Windows and
sequel server Delphi is what whirlen
Pascal became so it's it's sort of a an
edge platform in terms of what people
currently use but it's still fairly
effective um Josh Platt smart platform
Java groovy and MongoDB and that
supports both the smart activities and
the fire activities pure area that's
where yo out comes out of in the
Netherlands they have a dotnet with
MongoDB implementation available so you
a Chen has clients in Java
you have other implementations and
there's a growing list of these
particular activities so now we get into
a little bit of what can you do with
this so you have three
access through fire to the granular data
a number of different ways that you can
do that how do you do that well if
you've ever put a trace on your on your
HDPE stack and said this what's actually
happening this is what's happening under
the covers and this is a request for a
resource and fire for get me the patient
whose family name is Smith and whose
given name is John that's that's how
simple it looks prior specifications
with hl7 would given you if you printed
them out it would probably be this thick
pages of XML five to ten pages of XML
this is what it looks like in fire
somebody said fast as an engineer the
line of code I can write to actually
make that request as five lines of code
to do that as an hl7 version 3
transaction after I figure out all the
schemas so I can write that in less than
five minutes that haven't compiled and
running against Graham's test server if
I were doing that version three five
hours it really is a lot of work that
has to go on with schema and everything
else maybe not even five hours perhaps
if I have to start tweaking the schemas
and doing some other stuff five days
version two if I want to issue that
query using hl7 version two and I
already have the infrastructure I can
write the code to issue that transaction
in about fifteen minutes fast I can
write that code fast what's the most
important thing for interoperability how
fast can people turn your problems into
solutions oh by the way every engineer
that gets out of software development
program in school knows how to do this
they do not know how to interpret hl7
version 3 XML I can teach them it will
take me about two years
okay I can teach them I could actually
hand them volume chapters 1 2 & 3 of
version 2 and say read this and don't
mean the stuff and they could do it in
about two weeks
through reading it version 3 they may
never get there with fire literally
they're going online to some of these
reference servers these open source
reference servers that are out there
today
and you're getting seniors in high
school
hitting epics online test server where
people can go play in the Internet in
their sandbox seniors in high school
that's what's fast about fire this is
what the output looks like oh and yeah
it's still plenty brackets and it's
still pretty ugly but it's human
readable as opposed to the hl7 version 3
which was all about everything being
pristine and based on a common model and
something that rket only an architect
could love this I can hand to an
engineer I can I can even teach you how
to read this right here's the name its
uses official the family part of it is
Smith the given part of it is John right
you can read that and you can see the
same sort of thing here where you can
read and understand that no more
counting pipes and hats and little
filters and your BP messages or trying
to figure out what this weird
construction of an entity with a type
code in a mood code what all that other
stuff means it's all pretty clear there
now you take that same stuff that you
get back this is what you actually have
to write and you can do a put you know
there were a very simple HTTP requests
to store information on the web server
there are post which is what you
typically do when you fill out forms oh
they're written or edited using the same
format so
it's in the same XML or it's in the same
JSON format um and then you can get
version history through a variety of
different operations furthermore I can
create new operations to say hey you
know here is an order for an imaging
service which you go please check to see
if that order is appropriate according
to AUC criteria I got a patient who's
got a headache and I want to do an MRI
scan on his head and it can come back
with a response after going through and
just looking at the order and who did
the order and the indications and the
service could say oh I got some more
questions this that's worst headache in
the patient's life so you could define
that operation you can put that in a
profile and specify how to conform to
that profile and now you have something
that somebody can interrogate in or
integrate with and figure out how to
make this stuff work so priority define
several operations one of them is this
notion of I want to translate a concept
where might you use that so you want to
translate concepts from what the
standards used by one country to
energies by another country so standards
used by the US and maybe the rest of the
world like icd-9 and icd-10 or or
perhaps crossing from the clinical
domain to the financial domain so I've
got my code sno-med CT what's this write
code for it so that I can get paid right
I've got a link code what's the actual
code I have to use to order the lab
that's associated with that in my
institution so lots of different uses
for these sorts of operations um the
specifications are very easy to read
they're all available on the web they
have a sort of a simple XML
all representation of how you can read
it engineers find this very readable
compared to the hl7 schemas which we
look at and we go my head just exploded
all of that all of that stuff that's in
color is clickable and we'll take you
through the entire specification you
find out that the basic resource has an
identifier has a code has a subject when
you see this shape you know it's
pointing to another resource these
resources are linked together what's the
what about linking what's restful about
what we're using resources and these
resources are linked to each other so we
don't have to completely recess off' I a
subject as being any kind of resource or
an author as being a resources
associated with some kind of person we
can say point to the patient or the
related person or the practitioner who
created this thing that's something who
they are how do we develop this well we
had an hl7 version 3 we had our own
tooling we spent years developing it and
there was tens perhaps even hundreds of
thousands of dollars building
specialized software that ran in Visio
and doing a lot of those other stuff
today nope use a spreadsheet fill out
the tabs there are six key tabs that you
have to fill out the instructions tell
you what what tabs you have to fill out
how to fill them out and then this runs
through you save it in XML format this
runs through and you're able now to turn
that into the fire specification okay so
now we get a little bit to the
interactive piece of this and I realize
some people have to go but very quickly
so what problems do you think fire could
help you solve so you had the problem
with reconciliation so what's the first
step that you have to do to be able to
reconcile
so you have to find a common vocabulary
so you have to be able access the
vocabulary that's associated with all of
the different pads you might even have
to translate i ordering meds now and NDC
codes and later i'm going to do rxnorm
right yeah sorry I said in DC and rxnorm
are exactly the ones that every engine
problem translates to one and only one
rxnorm code there's an operation for
that fire to do that translation you
also have to be able to get access to
what it what the medication is the
specific medication statements patient
says I'm taking this what medications
have been supplied to the patient
through supply you have resources to get
at that sort of thing um somebody I'm
sorry
h-i-m person left so anybody else have a
particular problems if you're looking to
solve with fire here this how how would
you find like where things are how what
things are called for example let's say
I need you know like I'm thinking about
we're doing a lot of work in quality
measures and there are a lot of kind of
arbitrary kinds of coded values that are
stored in there and how would I
determine if they're if they're in there
or not and what they would be called is
there some sort of general searching
scheme okay
so different kinds of resources or so
for your quality measures let's take a
quick look at something here so for your
quality measures you have a quality
measure and it might be for patients
with symptoms of acute myocardial
infarction and and and the way they
define a mi is going to be you know this
list of diagnosis codes maybe or
something like that it's the question
you're asking how do I find out
what those codes what that list that
they reference in the quality measure is
talking about how do you measure talks
about well you have to hand the patience
of information sheets and there's some
essentially arbitrary coded structure
where somebody checks off a box and it's
stored in the EHR that they handed them
this information sheet how do I find now
oh so now you're talking a little bit
about data elements what's the date
where's that data element located so
there is actually a resource for dealing
with data elements and tying data
elements to structure definitions so
that you could actually describe the
structure of the EHR data Indy elements
you could take you were you know if you
happened to be one of the lucky ones
your organization has somewhere a a
library of here's our here's here's the
structure of our information here's our
knowledge base about where all of this
stuff is stored it's a fairly extensive
activity to put it together it took six
months and ahima to even come up with a
paper to talk about what needed to be
done to do this so I know the activity
itself is fairly expensive but if you
have that you can describe the structure
of your with the data that's in your EHR
as data elements um in some of the
current activities that are involved
with clinical research at the national
standards level they're taking advantage
of data elements and linking them up
with questionnaires to be able to
support asking clinical questions
supporting clinical trials research as
well as patient-centered outcomes
research and some of that activity going
on at that level is being funded by
P Corrie so we should probably wrap up
the next a few minutes but we are about
we're about there because we're at my
last slide and so so the way I handled
this presentation is is my questions are
for you and so this last slide is not
the typical question slide but it's it's
more me asking you so how are you going
to explore further and what can you do
to get more engaged and and what sorts
of roadblocks might be running into okay
great so I can help you with that
there's also a Skype chat you should get
on where you can actually ask other
people who might be closer to that other
people like if you have to use a
structured encoded element so this is
one of the areas where fire differs from
hl7 version 3 in that hl7 version 3 was
all about semantic interoperability in
my magic phrase and we talked about
instead of the patterns of use the
patterns of meaning an hl7 version 3
standard was all about the patterns of
me the fire standard is written in terms
of patterns of use everything in fire
has a mapping so the standard itself has
in it mappings back to the origins the
origin standards from which those things
came from and that gives you the meaning
so there's and there's mappings for
every fire thing back to the rim just
about
if you want to learn more about fire
there's lots of different ways I would
suggest you start with going to hl7 org
slash fire the other thing that you can
do is that you can go to hl7 and create
yourself a log in from the hl7 org page
if you go to walk go to the when you get
to the page it will actually give you a
link where you can log in if you go
there you can create a login you do not
have to be a member start exploring go
to the workgroups resources there's
actually now a fire work group was
officially created the last working
group meeting sign up for the mailing
lists well there's also a Skype chat if
you're on skype and you want to be added
to the chat to see what the developers
are actually doing now by the way that
chats very geeky I'll be happy to add
you to it I know we are sort of running
out of resources on the number of people
we can add to a Skype chat who knew
there was a limit apparently there is
though but that's a way that you were
one of your developers can get engaged
feel free to email me anybody who wants
to grab one I do have a handful of
business cards my day job is about
helping people to understand standards
and I can tell you more about how you
can get connected and I hope at least
for some of you that you've achieved
your goals today I'm coming here and
thank you for having